good evening friends and family are
remembering a young athlete who was
killed over the weekend thanks for
joining us i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis kieron hatchet died on
sunday police say he was shot right at
the intersection of rainbow and
westcliff after leaving a party now
there has been an outpouring of
condolences and on social media now a
candlelight vigil you're looking at a
live picture from the east las vegas
family park that is on washington and
lamb as you can see dozens of people
gathered here to remember key ron kate
houston speaking to hatchet's family
still trying to cope with what was such
a sudden loss
he was like our angel the family and
friends of kieron hatchet are stunned he
didn't do anything gang related he
didn't do any drugs
he was not a bad kid at all juantrell
lovett is the only sister to the 23 year
old she describes her brother as a
family man a loving friend and a
dedicated athlete he loved college
he had dreams of
making it to the nba or being a coach in
the nba hatchet was in town on a visit
from college and was supposed to meet up
with family on sunday when he was shot
levitt says he was declared brain dead
and died during surgery it could have
been any one of us
we would we would have chose to go
take me
the oldest
i've been here
i'm my brother hatchet's family doesn't
know who shot at him and his friends and
is calling on the community to end
senseless acts of gun violence this has
to stop
this has to stop
you guys it's different ways to resolve
things because people are losing their
lives
they didn't think to ask or
to wonder or to know who was in the car
they
just took his life kate houston 8 news
now just so tough for this family right
now there is no word of a shooter in
custody the family asking one with any
information to please come forward